controlling a breath and being able to
take in more oxygen as needed the two
methods of increasing performance that
are largely neglected in modern training
the term vo2 max refers to the maximum
amount of oxygen a person is able to
breathe in and utilize during training
by increasing the size efficiency and
strength of the lungs you can give this
a huge boost while elite athletes
practice such things as running while
holding their breath is a practice that
is yet to venture into mainstream that's
a shame as this form of training can
benefit everyone in the gym in the
office and at rest being able to take in
and use more oxygen is crucial for
improving your cardiovascular
performance as well as your work
capacity but increasing your oxygen
intake on each breath also has other
less obvious benefits too for one that
helps you to increase oxygen supply to
your brain that results in a sharper
intellect a greater focus and awareness
and even a better mood what's more is
that once it can control your breath it
can also take a degree of conscious
control over the autonomic nervous
system as seen in the wim HOF method as
you can see there are huge benefits to
training your breathing or to put it
another way there are huge benefits to
training your lungs like Aquaman
what you will learn over the course of
this video is that we are actually
designed to thrive by spending more time
submerged in cold water this is a
natural stimulus that many of us have
lost and we all have untapped potential
that is unlocked by spending time
underwater or simulating it with breath
training and the results of
incorporating this training can be truly
profound so Aquaman is able to breathe
underwater and remain there indefinitely
unfortunately we cannot achieve quite
the same level of comfort underwater
however there are many ways to learn to
take in more air and control it for
longer with each breath one less obvious
method for training your vo2 Max is to
train your lungs themselves or more
specifically to Train the intercostal
muscles and diaphragm to help expand the
contract the lungs more powerfully this
can increase the amount of air you're
able to breathe in with each attempt
thereby filling your blood with more
oxygen this results in enhanced
performance greater strength and a
longer time to fatigue one way to do
this is with something called in
spirit ory muscle training or IMT this
involves using an apparatus or other
methods to add resistance to your usual
breathing the result is that your lungs
need to work harder to achieve the same
level of oxygen saturation something
similar can be achieved with altitude
masks that you see people wearing in the
gym these products came under fire due
to false advertising they don't actually
simulate a high-altitude environment but
what they do do however is to strengthen
your lungs and improve oxygen delivery
during intense exercise so they're not
useless that said you can achieve a
similar effect much more cheaply by
breathing through a straw in your mouth
with time this will allow you to take in
more oxygen on every single breath when
training and at rest you can easily
purchase devices called breath trainers
online that you can use in your spare
time as well and these will help to
conveniently engage in this kind of
training anywhere want to take this a
step further
practicing breath holding might be an
exercise that can offer benefits on par
with the wim HOF technique or meditation
is something I think everyone should be
doing in other words in fact breath
holding was traditionally practiced by
Yogi's but has been gradually forgotten
by many of them breath holding can
further strengthen the intercostal
muscles and diaphragm it also helps to
teach the body to become more efficient
in this use of oxygen increases carbon
dioxide
tolerance that means that you don't have
that urge to breathe as quickly boosts
mitochondrial density that means you can
produce more energy in your cells and
raises EPO levels in short the teachers
need to be able to perform with a lower
oxygen content in your blood making you
more efficient at using it this is why
some athletes now practice running and
engaging in other physical activities
while holding their breath which I'll
talk about later something to keep in
mind is that co2 is actually a very
useful substance that helps us to
extract the oxygen from our blood cells
practicing breath holding also teaches
you to control your own response to
physiological stress and to recognize
the signs in your own body that can help
to improve your overall mind-body
connection and give you zen-like control
over your own emotional response if
you're going to reach impressive
breath-hold times then you need to learn
to relax your body and mind in the face
of stress over time these changes can
drastically improve your athletic
performance lower your resting heart
rate and significantly reduce anxiety
you know start seeing noticeable
benefits within one month there are two
primary ways to train
breath-holding one is by gradually
increasing the amount of time that you
hold your breath in one go which is
known as Oh to training and this uses a
fixed recovery period usually of around
2 minutes to expel all co2 the aim is to
improve the body's efficiency when
working with low oxygen and over time
you'll increase the challenge the other
is to Train by reducing the amount of
time between breath holds known as co2
training here you'll keep the breath
hold consistent at around 1 to 2 minutes
this should be about 50% of your static
personal best but will gradually
decrease the rest time from between 2
minutes to about 15 seconds this results
in a buildup of co2 which teaches the
body to improve co2 tolerance and
thereby overcoming that burning desire
to breathe that pesky thing typically
you'll follow co2 and o2 tables
respectively which provides you with a
guided structure for gradually building
up on each practice but at the same time
you should tailor this to your own
current ability level and not push
yourself too far there are obviously
inherent dangers here and you need to be
really careful you also need to think
about your environment the great thing
is that this is also highly meditative
and it's a fantastic way of building
tremendous and will power and focus the
interesting thing is that the amount of
time you can hold your breath on land is
going to be shorter than the amount of
time you can hold your breath underwater
so when you dive you'll find you can
dive even longer and even lower this is
thanks to something called the mammalian
dive reflex which kicks in in response
to cold water on the face well we have
special receptors this reflex lowers the
heart rate by 10 to 25 percent increases
blood flow to the vital organs contracts
the spleen to release more blood and
even alters internal pressure is quite
amazing and it shows that we all have an
untapped genetic heritage that would
allow us to swim more like Aquaman it
shows that our bodies are designed to
adapt to this stimulus for our purposes
though dry training as it is known is
safer and more practical for the most
part but we can occasionally tap into
these innate acraman abilities as needed
advanced level coaches now introducing
this kind of training for their
sprinters cyclists and more but in the
interests of said specific adaptations
to impose demands they also train
breath-holding during their workouts as
reported in the oxygen advantage which
is a fantastic book by Patrick McGowan
are tasked with such challenges as
holding my breath whilst running the
last 30 meters of a 400 or 800 meter
sprint he also recommends athletes to
hold their breath after exhalation
rather than after inhalation as with the
methods just described this
significantly decreases the blood oxygen
saturation and ups carbon dioxide
concentration this is ideal for
stimulating the production of red blood
cells also reportedly improves the
lactate threshold McCowan recommends
sprinters to practice jogging 80 to 100
paces whilst breath-holding with six
repetitions and a minute rest in between
want to go even further beyond if
improving your ability to hold breath
has cognitive and athletic benefits then
surely we should be looking to the
people who are able to hold their
breaths longer than anyone else and who
would that be free divers free divers
who regularly hold their breath for over
10 minutes magician David Blaine
achieved a similarly impressive feat
when he trained himself to hold his
breath for 17 minutes and 4 seconds
during a televised stunt what strategies
do they used to achieve these superhuman
feats one answer is something called
oxygen packing this involves breathing
in to take in as much oxygen as you
possibly can and then breathing in more
on top of that it takes several
additional gulps when your lungs are
fully filled up the logic here is that
you are physically stretching your lungs
and increasing lung capacity that way
normally when we breathe in and we think
we're at max capacity we're actually
still leaving a fair amount of space
left for extra oxygen when attempting
your personal best incorporate this
method in order to see how it might
facilitate greater results over time it
might have long-term advantages as
mentioned breath control is also
extremely beneficial when it comes to
controlling your autonomic nervous
system we see this most clearly with the
wim HOF method and Tomo meditation this
is all possible because the way we
breathe is able to stimulate the vagus
nerve that nerve returns information
about our physiological state to the
brain in order to provide a two-way
communication in short when we breathe
quickly it likely means we're either
training or in danger this information
is relayed to the brain via the nerve
which leads to an increase in hormones
like adrenaline cortisol that means
greater strength and performance but it
also means you breathe even quicker and
you place a strain on your body you feel
more anxious and panicked in your
vision becomes more tunneled that's why
it's so destructive to spend all day in
a state of chronic stress and it's why
it's so unfortunate that most of us also
exacerbate this problem by using shallow
breathing due to poor posture and bad
habits by using belly breathing and a
whole range of additional breathing
techniques you can undo this damage and
start to better oxygenate your whole
body in the full article linked in the
description down below over the website
I go over a number of different
breathing techniques that you can use to
further train your ability to thrive on
low oxygen and to stay in a state of
calm throughout the day that includes
things like belly breathing the fourfold
breath and minding the gate I also talk
a bit more about the wim HOF method go
and check that out if you'd like to
learn more about that so if you want to
train for Aquaman like breathing it's
more than possible you can learn to hold
your breath potentially up to 20 minutes
at a time taking advantage of the body's
natural adaptability and affinity for
the water did you know that there's a
tribe in the Andaman Sea called the
Moken these people get a huge proportion
of their food from the sea bed and as
such they've actually adapted to be able
to see clearly underwater they have a
unique ability to bend the lenses in
their eyes in such a way as to counter
the refraction of the water while also
narrowing their people's to the limits
of human performance
unfortunately it's thought that this is
only possible for young children
nevertheless it demonstrates that the
water like so many elements in nature
has the ability to transform our
physical performance in surprising ways
the elements trained us back in the day
our lack of breath holding and water
exposure is just another cause of our
weakened domesticated state in modern
times by reintroducing breath holding
and breath control we can potentially
tap in to profound improvements in our
physical and mental performance running
faster for longer staying calm and more
focused and enjoying greater health and
of course exploring the ocean depths
like Aquaman himself
I hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around that
helps me out immensely subscribe to the
channel if you want more like this I
have lots of cool stuff on the way of
course if you want a whole lot more then
check out the link in the description
down below to preorder my book super
functional training they say eBook PDF
and it basically is the sum of
everything I've done on the channel all
combined into a single tome alongside a
program designed to train your body but
also your mind and your health and much
more you can find more information in
that link and you'll also be able to
save $10 off the usual price if you
pre-order it now the book releases on
the 4th of November at which point
you'll be emailed your copy along with
the additional supporting materials so
that's it for now thanks a ton for
watching this and stay tuned for much
more bye for now